okay welcome everyone to the Thursday
evening
first class we'll have another one today
after this one so we're gonna continue
going over some of the key games from
the recently concluded single Cup
tournament between Shaq mama dr.oz and
against Magnus Carlsen world number
three Shaq is playing white against
world number one Carlson black very
interesting game Mahmoud Yadav really
needed to try to play for the win in
this game to try to qualify for lambda G
city finals so he went for something
offbeat so we have we have a you know
sort of a group felt right and here okay
you can take and play the exchange
foundation but he played an interesting
move Knight bTW - just a natural move if
you capture he wants to take back with a
knight 85 very rare move from Carlsen
which has which has only been played
four times previously okay and two times
it was played by none other than Vasily
even choke Ivan choke okay and you know
it seems like both players were trying
to get into a position where you know
they have some fresh ideas you know they
have some new ideas so that's what it
seems like the both players were trying
to do p3
a for Bishop a tree a bee a bee castles
so we reach this position now White
Castle from the first glance it looks
like it's really nice for white yeah
White has much more development his
pieces are wealth as it looks like it's
nice for white but it's not so simple
because black will have his development
Bishop f5 so I want to get to the
critical moment Queen e2 night a six
this is movies a novelty means never
been played before the other previous
game was nigh be d7 take take each three
and yeah he won't shoot game against
even shook wait wait a sec wait a sec
even shook so anyway White is a little
bit better here but why White was better
but he end up losing actually I did six
Knight e5
Knight e4
[Music]
white wants to play rock fc-1 and enjoy
the advantage and I enjoy the fact that
he is pressing here so that's why Black
has to do something so he played 94
takes
ninety-four
Bishop before now Bishop takes e4 plate
another idea was Bishop h3 okay I was
another idea to try Bishop h3 because
the point is after after he is forced to
go to a5 the pawn structure looks a
little bit wobbly here okay white maybe
a little bit better here takes takes and
from the first glance from the first
glance it looks like I mean white is
doing great it seems like I mean he's
got an active Queen he's got a strong
night a good Bishop here as well and now
he's about to play rock FC one it seems
like Shaq you know he's enjoying a very
nice advantage against Carlsen here but
from here on I want you to try to think
and try to play the next few moves like
Coulson and you know very precise play
by him to equalize and simply neutralize
the contra play so let's see ok Queen c7
is a possibility
yeah Queen c7 recap c1 and 97 now you
need you need a nice solid move b7 pawn
is quite important here so you don't
want to just give it a sheen that line
it's a good idea to bring the knight to
defy but you don't want to rush with it
and lose it
rugby why is it possible you want to
give up upon you don't want to give up
upon yeah but I mean the alternatives
are to give up a pawn or do what your
pawn is under attack you need to protect
the decision I mean not always you're
gonna play active sometimes you have to
play solid okay now rook FC won it okay
see one seems like very nice but here
it's actually very strong move Knight
c7r she she's smooth and look at that
Knight is establishing himself on d5
Quincy for now the idea is to put
pressure on f7 right look at that one
- very concrete idea Quincy for now
block has two options right Bishop e5 or
is six correct and so what do you think
is the best thing to do here but then I
think after rook F c1 it's a little bit
of a trouble right it seems like after
this your knight on a six it's not
ideally placed it's very hard to get in
you know you cannot go ahead
well does it solve the problems Ashish
doesn't solve all the problems still
maybe take 97 96 still I think some
serious problems here block is
experiencing here now attacking this guy
look at that move look at that now
you're losing the pot 965
I D that's what causes that correct
decision Adi excellent yes
eliminating the opponent strong right
but it's kind of counterintuitive yeah
it's not the move that you would just
it's a little counterintuitive takes but
this has to be followed down with
another very powerful move here
optically it looks very bad the night
stuck on a rim efore pawn is hanging a
seven points loss it looks like for sure
this has got to be an advantage for
white but not so easy
absolutely Queen III strong play then
it's nice
look at that move queen d3 now trying to
force the exchange of the Queen's and if
that occurs you know the pawn on d3 is
gonna be nice nice and powerful rook AC
one bring in the rook into the game see
one looks a little bit more logical but
maybe he wanted to keep that to play
rook F T one okay takes takes and looks
bad yeah he for pawn is falling what did
he play here what did he play here
to see it it's black to play yeah white
is threatened to take the pawn f5 yeah
but that's creates lots of weaknesses
yeah sheesh the problem is this pawn
what to do with the pawn yeah cannot
protect upon excellent yeah so let's try
to play active instead how can we play
active here
so rocky c8r appreciate what first of
all first of all isn't this just drops
polish
okay but this is discipline I mean as
far as I know this is a pawn right I
mean I don't see where is the
compensation here at least not
immediately right
no well night c5u can I take it yeah but
okay
well it looks like well you can equalize
I don't know okay well let's go back
this is not very canoe let's put it this
way it's not very convincing
okay guys you have to play strong you
have to play like a world champion okay
what did he play here Caleb you know the
move
no Caleb does another movie okay you
guys were here though now the game was
played here this is round eight round
eight you guys were here before I have
cloudy oh yes if he takes before push
and look at that finally the night comes
in into the game yeah and he's attacking
and win the pond so so he is forced to
play rook c6 attacking the knight well
okay it only move rook c1
and a for a moment it seems like how is
black and a get out of this it looks
terrible the night is stuck on a six be
five bonus week eserve upon us week
efore opponents week I mean
dink-dink Ashish think you have to
calculate rook not be a truck CA that
seems dangerous that is 610 is then you
I so cement a bishop on d6 and that
would be a very powerful Bishop there
are D before them there should be two I
know by your knight is stuck on a corner
you know if you play before this should
be 2 and then I put the bishop on d4 and
I'm controlling the only open file and
the night is pretty bad here you know at
least to say you know at least to say
so what do we do 98
yeah he goes here well you cannot just
go 97 I mean you can but this your upon
Falls maybe I go here first I know you
don't have a very nice pawn structure
you know lots of weaknesses ok maybe
it's holdable but it's lots of
weaknesses so but here Carlson had
actually maybe it is correct and here
actually Carlson had a strong move in
mind yes well now right now your rook is
hanging mm-hmm I mean earlier it could
have but not here because you know you
cannot take this guy because the rook is
hanging strong move yeah he mentioned
that he missed this from a far away
because he he thought this was just
looking great for me 97 I will take tour
take only seven he thought this is just
great this is excellent but nope not so
easy King f8 and now he wants to take
the bishop on a3 so bishop before his
plate 96
now rooks are connected Bishop a5 again
it seems like Knight is stuck
but now the King comes in
in fact if black puts the king on these
seven look see it maybe he will be a
little bit better so this was played
right here
and now he realizes it's better for him
to sacrifice the spawn but room black's
pawn structure if you take here now now
I'm on King g6 it takes the night it's
going to be a healthy pawn you know and
this Bishop is not very well placed here
so he upped 46 what caused this is the
game he did play King FA that's how the
game right here yeah so takes this is
the game it takes okay so what is their
evaluation here let's take a look at
because this is this was a bit confusing
with difficult position to understand
what's going on
yeah but the knight on the tree is
strong yeah it's very powerful and your
knight be a wishbone 85 I mean it's it's
more like a blocker here than anything
else okay Bishop on a5 it's more like a
blocker but King f1 look at faith ashish
immediately you run into a little
problem there black wants to play rook
f8 and even take so if they Roxy it
first
you're not going to be able to prevent
black from getting the rook to the
second rank so you have to be quick to
create your own culture play so you play
the check and push it's very important
for y to create contra play otherwise
black would simply play rook c2 and when
they have to pawn okay so this b5 is
very important to create its own contra
play
yes well that's another it's the f2 pawn
is not that important boy whitish is
gonna push the pawn so check comes back
now he wants to take back on f2 with the
check or even consider knighted so
strong defensive move here by momma Dee
are off this was a big game because
mommy tiara was really trying to win it
you can but he will play get let's say
King d5 check he just goes candy 5 you
know Ashish
now if you check with what rook King
comes up and it protects so you rookies
on b6 so what's the idea here
what did he play d8 risky risky move
guys very risky came back so he doesn't
take on f2 with the check and now let's
see if you play rook F to look at this
move
check if you take the rookie say again
check take
it's a nice forcing line and in a draw
huh so yeah it's for this yeah I think
kg1 is really difficult it's very
difficult the best defense to prevent
black from capturing on f2 with the
check so this is a really tough move to
play no I mean Carlson has a Troy here
if he wants but he didn't want to draw
so you play g5 he wants to put a pawn on
g4 b 8b v
kingi - because you cannot take here
because of b7 so you cannot really
capture so you just place the move Kim G
- G for fixing the constructor h3
that gives a little escape square for
the white king so h5 takes takes again
you cannot take the bishop because of b7
and now he goes Bishop c3 the point of
this move is to put the bishop on d4 to
give a strong check but this should be
force so that's why you cannot take back
with the rook because of the bishop d4
check so if I was played to control the
d4 square rook g8 trying to capture the
pawn king c4 check
back you cannot play rook c5 that would
be a very bad mistake because of b7 and
quaint
check
trick
so the question was either to repeat to
make a drawer finally go for this idea
so he did this he takes
check
but the problem for black is all the
palms are fixed and there is it's very
difficult to do anything so you played
here
kinky to e6 you can get fun the most
important thing is not to allow the King
to get to a d1 face it not f1 if you go
to f1 then King comes to Devon it's
probably still draw but you already
cutting it close and now it goes here
there's no palm breakthroughs take so
check
extra pawn but triple pawns in huh
if this part was only five it's
completely different very very good
winning chances but with the triple
pants it's just very difficult to do
anything check it again it was a
hard-fought draw hard-fought draw and
it's the interesting opening against the
groom field I want to wait a couple of
students who arrive late so I just want
to show the opening part so this was a
draw between Mamedov and Carlson so is
the Grunfeld opening okay and it is
interesting night BD too so it's
something to consider
okay yeah most common move by forest 65
and that's the probably thousands of
games played in this position and they
played this 95 so this is the microphone
in other movies I think will be trees
another move Gruffudd is such a
difficult opening to get advantage
against so people are keep analyzing and
trying to find ideas against it it's
very very hard
thank you guys for attending this class
we're gonna take a short break now and
get ready for the second lecture we have
for another lecture after this class
okay so if you have time stick around
for the next one okay
[Music]